at 6 24 royal watchers are wondering if  and when buckingham palace will respond  to prince harry and meghan's interview  with oprah  well the couple accused the royal family  of racism  lies and indifference to megan's  suicidal pleas for help  no official response yet from the palace  more than 17  million people tuned in sunday night for  the two-hour interview  according to nielsen it's the largest  prime time audience for  any entertainment special this year the  interview was also cbs's most  live streamed event outside of the nfl  and super bowl sunday  oprah with megan and harry is available  to watch on the cbs  app and cbs.com